Book of Shadows Blair Witch to where do
I even start so if you guys saw my
review for the Blair Witch Project you
know that I'm covering the - Blair Witch
theatrical films that came before the
upcoming new film that's going to be
coming out in September I thought it'd
be fun to talk about these films I
enjoyed talking about the first and I
actually have some interesting things to
say about Book of Shadows because it's
very easy to sit here and say oh my god
this movie is horrible it's terrible
blah blah blah I hate this movie it's an
abomination against humanity it should
not exist but there's actually a lot of
really interesting behind-the-scenes
stuff that went on with the making of
Book of Shadows this films about a group
of tourists who are cashing in on the
Blair Witch Project phenomena one guy in
particular who later got more famous for
being the star of the TV show Burn
Notice
this guy has set up the Blair Witch hunt
it's a trip through the area of
Burkittsville Maryland where the people
who shot the Blair Witch Project movie
filmed their movie and these people go
into the woods excited about the
phenomenon of the Blair Witch about the
movie about the things relating to the
movie and some really serious shit goes
down they start seeing things they start
turning on one another and no one really
knows exactly what's going on especially
the audience because this movie really
is very bad but the movie that the
director was trying to make is a movie I
would love to see if a place like shout
factory got their hands on the
director's cut of this film or could
perhaps contact the director and make
the director's cut that's something I
think would be worthwhile it certainly
would be better than what we got which
is a studio assembled horror movie
disaster our design Entertainment saw
something in the Blair Witch Project not
in the film but in the box office
returns and so they really wanted to
make a sequel very fast and what we got
was this hodgepodge reassembled movie
with reshoot scenes to be included in
the movie to make it seem more gory and
more violent Marilyn Manson music to be
inserted in the film to make it seem
more rock and punk like even though the
original director did not want to make a
film like that he was going for a more
satirical sorry
a stick film it was supposed to be a
more lighthearted film with some scary
and thrilling elements which made sense
because the public perception of the
Blair Witch Project turned from
horrifying to okay I get it it's fake
let's make fun of this this isn't very
good that happened really fast and so it
made sense to go in that direction but
artisan entertainment wanted a more
straightforward horror film there is a
very good video about this on YouTube
from the channel good bad flicks I let
the link for that in the description
below this guy explores a lot of the
making of this movie and how it could
have been better as well as one of the
most interesting parts of this movie
which is hidden messages that appear
throughout the movie it was linked into
the website and the viral marketing of
it there's even a scene where a
character is speaking in Reverse and if
you reverse what she's saying you get a
sentence that you could then enter on
the website and you could be one of the
few people that decipher this film's
hidden clues they actually did try to
make some really cool things in this
movie but unfortunately the film we got
is shit for this review it really
doesn't matter that the director was
trying to make a better movie because
the movie we have is not that movie this
movie jumps all over the place the
structure of this movie feels like
someone took every reel of film mashed
it all together and just put it through
the Machine hoping that a coherent film
would thus play out for us on the
screens the weird reshoot scenes that
are included into this film to heighten
the violence and have strange out of
place flashback sequences and
flash-forward sequences show us that
they were just way too many cooks in the
kitchen on this movie because the actual
product despite whatever the director
was hoping to make the final product is
absolute shit this is a boring unfunny
mess of a movie with way too many ideas
going back and forth with performances
that really don't always work especially
when you insert the idiotic reshoot
scenes that the studio forced them to do
and the gruesome unnecessarily violent
scenes that were reshot and thrown into
this movie take away from that hinting
from that suggestion that the first film
did so well it's almost like the studio
just said hey what does every horror
franchise ever do well
they always make a really effective
first film and then they get really gory
and violent and repetitive and they all
suck hope II should do that with Book of
Shadows
speaking of Book of Shadows there's no
book of shadows in this movie that's
easily the most hilarious part of the
studio changes they wanted the subtitle
to be Book of Shadows and there is no
such item there's that's amazing that's
incredible actually then how did that
happen I'm blown away by that guys in
the end despite whatever movie they were
trying to make that would have been
better trust me I would love to see a
director's cut of that movie the final
film we got was an awful jumbled
reassembled mess with way too many
people overseeing this production when
one vision would have just been fine
enough I'm gonna give Book of Shadows
Blair Witch to a d-minus simply because
there are a few effective performances
and there is a good idea in this movie
but it just wasn't harnessed as I said
because of all that interference so guys
I'm excited for Blair Witch the new film
coming out very soon I had fun talking
about these two films with you guys
thanks very much for watching and if you
like this you can click right here and
get stuck mine eyes